today on stick to football we have a lot
to cover the NFL trade deadline that
wasn't we have some college football
news how does it all affect the NFL
Draft because it is that time of year
we're gonna preview and pick this
weekend's games we're gonna get you
ready for tailgate tour which is a week
away we just got home when we leave in a
week we are going to because it's
Halloween while we're recording give you
our top five hauntings and some draft on
draft questions but before we get into
it guys a question for you that I
purposefully left out of the rundown Mel
O'Connor welcome to show I should just
want time to see how long I can go
without let you go right here's the
question of the day what is your
favorite Halloween candy I'm gonna go
with the racist pumpkins or whatever is
traditional that's a Reese's Peanut
anything for whatever they have yeah
just about anything from them is number
one I feel like that should be consensus
although I know it isn't but a lot
actually I really do and I feel like
there's somehow better when they're in a
different shape than the circle I don't
quite understand it but like they're
just better that way no butter yeah it's
just they're so good I think that is
mine and I'm not just you know catering
to our friends at Reese's and Jim naggy
I like a good Snickers but here's the
thing about a Snickers if you get one
and this might not happen on the coast
but in the Midwest you sometimes get
stale candy bars
if you've ever bitten into a stale
Snickers it's disgusting so I have a
trick melot you've seen me do this I
push on them and if it's soft you can
you can buy it if it's not if you can't
like make an indention with your finger
on the candy bar don't buy it this is
news to me okay Oh beep dirt I like this
from Matt yeah at the corner store I
always like whenever I buy something
like that
I always thumb it every time because
I've gotten burned you Savin a lot more
when I lived up in Albany because that's
a lot like just a shadier of a place
where I lived and you get stale and
expired [ __ ] all the time
so it's like if it's a habit that I
think I'll die with every time half the
dummy our listeners learn something new
I feel like every episode it's just life
hack after life hack how to buy candy
bar / beef jerky because we really have
to be careful because it will be want it
it'll get hard and no one wants that no
one was that ok let's get into show gate
tour one week away we will be on the
quad at Alabama for the Alabama LSU game
I'm ordering koozies as we're doing the
podcast we're gonna have koozie stickers
Melo and I are bringing cornhole we have
food getting catered we have beer that
we're bringing or I have non-alcoholic
drinks I hope I should priorto
maybe lasting so gonna have two waters
yeah it'll be it'll be a lot of fun I'm
very excited about it hopefully you guys
will come out it's free you don't have a
ticket to the game you don't have a
ticket to the tailgate just come out and
I tweeted this and I don't think we've
ever done this before but this is like
open to the away team as well yeah I
think course we cater to the home team I
don't know what kind of shirt I'm gonna
wear yet I don't know if I'm LSU or
Alabama for this one this is uh this is
a good one it's gonna be the game of the
year you're a little sick aren't you I'm
a little bit sick you gotta get right
this is gonna be a wicked tailgate I'll
tell you that right now hey if I can go
through TCU like I did last year oh
nothing can stop me at this point I mean
I was almost dead for that tailgate
Frank the TI I thought I thought that
was the end for you Mel oh I can't wait
for this tailgate because I think the
response we've had already people are
excited we do want to remind the Tiger
fans that you are welcome I know we
always support the home team by what
we're wearing and sometimes how we act
not all the time but we have a good time
with their own even when we went to
Baton Rouge last year we had plenty of
Georgia fans in the tailgate yeah and I
know a lot of people I know we've done
it like we go into a city like where do
we tailgate just come tailgate with us
we're gonna be very welcoming we're
gonna make know we're not allow like
Alabama fans to talk an aggressive
amount of [ __ ] so if you want like a
very friendly fan friendly tailgate come
hang out with us we're gonna have again
stickers koozies food and beer to give
away alright let's get into the actual
show because this is a buckle up it's
gonna be a bit of a long show tonight
and I know you guys are ok with that we
did not get a chance to talk about the
trade deadline because con
and I were in London and again thank you
to everyone over there for hosting us
making it a great week so let's start
here really the only big trade that
actually happened was the Giants and
Jets which the first time I think ever
that these two teams have traded litters
Williams doesn't even have to move he
just needs to change where he overs to
practice every day he goes from the Jets
to the Giants he's a pending free agent
and the terms of this deal guys make it
to where if the Giants don't keep him
then they have to pay less that the
traders at 2020 third rounder and a 2021
conditional pick it's a fourth rounder
if the Giants are able to Reese I'm
Leonard Williams before free agency it's
a fifth rounder if they don't the Jets
are gonna pay four million dollars of
Leonard Williams remaining salary it's
not a bat-like on paper right it's like
okay the Jets get something for a player
they're gonna lose anyway and you're
getting a pick earlier than you would or
sooner I should say then if it would be
a compensatory pick because that would
be the 2021 draft so you're basically
selling a guy to get a return faster for
the Giants I don't completely understand
Leonard Williams for them because they
just drafted Dexter Lawrence and they
have Dalvin Tomlinson but Dave gentlemen
is a fat kid in a candy store when it
comes to defensive tackles and they're
not paying a lot for a guy who was the
number six pick in the draft yeah I just
don't understand it because the Dexter
Lawrence thing I know they thought he
was gonna be more of a pass rusher
surprise he's not so then you bring in
Leonard Williams who I I don't think
he's a pass rusher either but you are
very DTAC already know I guess they just
still have to find a way to get an edge
rusher in there which was a need of
theirs last year but good for the Jets
you go out and you get some picks for a
guy that you weren't gonna keep around
anyway yeah and it sounded like there
weren't a lot of teams interested anyway
that's what's fascinating about this so
I think they actually come out in a
decent spot where if you're the Giants
making this deal the Giants are not
making the playoffs this year so they
should be reciting a young player that
they acquired in Leonard Williams where
you're expecting that to be a fourth
round pick in 2021 but you look at more
importantly here guys the third-round
pick in 2020 that should be a top 10
pick of that round and that's the most
important thing here the Jets obviously
would have preferred a late second-round
pick if they could have got it from a
contender there
any offers on the table like that those
offers went away they could have had
that in the offseason and they passed on
it they waited too long but at the end
of the day you get a pick that's a good
return on the giant side I'm kind of
with you here as Matt and both and both
of you guys alluded to this they're a
little crowded on the defensive line now
you didn't pay a lot to get a good
player in Leonard Williams he has not
been a great pass rusher for the Jets I
know people will throw the stats that
he's double-teams that he gets hurries
but not sacks at the end of the day the
impact wasn't there maybe that changes
when he puts on blue but right now it is
interesting for the Giants because I
actually think they have some talent up
front they've allocated some assets
upfront in this particular spot but Dave
gentlemen if you play in the front seven
he'll just keep on spending to load up
that area yeah it is it's surprising
just from that perspective because they
lose the team it does have needs but
this is is not what I would have called
wasn't neat so when when we heard like
oh the Giants might be active I really
thought okay we might see a linebacker
we might see a corner but to get a
defensive lineman
and again we've talked about this with
Laremy Tunsil we talked about it with
Jadeveon Clowney the winner Williams has
the most leverage almost of any player
in the NFL right now because he can he
in his agent walk in there and say you
traded a third and a fourth round pick
to keep me you're gonna pay whatever I
want basically so and I have heard the
Leonard Williams wants to stay in the
New York area so this is a good spot for
him I do want to turn this around though
because I know you mentioned Conner I
think it's fair to say right now Leonard
Williams was a disappointment as a draft
pick and I've had some Jets fans and
even just NFL fans say why should we be
applauding the Jets for getting a third
and a fourth for a guy who was the
number six pick in the draft and really
like on its head
yeah that's not great you really would
like to get a lot more for a player who
you drafted that early and that you
would expect to be now a building block
of that team but it didn't work out I
don't know if it's fair to say he was I
don't want to say he was overrated
necessarily but drafted too early and I
think this is why we can say okay why
did the Jets fail with all these early
picks year after year we were saying oh
my god I can't believe this guy fell to
the Jets linter was my number two
overall player in 2015 is supposed to be
the safest player in that draft he was
exactly supposed to be
that was not in hindsight a very good
draft class we came out of it all but
like this is why the Jets are still bad
is because you miss on guys like that
and then perfect segue you finally get a
good player and you piss him off Jamal
Adams whatever you want to say whether
you want to say they were shopping him
or they were talking answering the phone
on him and I know some people are really
like arguing semantics on this I wish
Jamal had said I don't appreciate that
you're taking calls on me because the
Patriots don't take calls on Tom Brady
spoiler they did once and like the Rams
that take calls on Aaron Donald if he
had said it Lee also did when he was
holding out right so I gave Jamal it
said hey if I'm supposed to be the face
this franchise of a team calls on me you
hang the phone up if he had been upset
about that I get it there is a
difference between a team shopping you
and a team answering the phone when
someone calls about you if it got to the
point of real negotiation again I think
he has a right to be upset given the
fact that they told him you're the face
of this team and everyone knows I'm very
Pro Jamal Adams he's one of my favorite
players in the league is one of my
favorite people in the league I will say
this the value of a strong safety is not
what the Jets are asking for in return
for him a first and two twos was the
rumor no strong safety in the NFL's
worth that anymore none there are not
many safeties regardless of strong or
free that are worth that right now I
mean we're not looking at Earl Thomas in
his prime I think that Jamal Adams is
limited on what he can do he's not a big
coverage guy so if you can't get a one
in two twos back for him
hell yeah you answer the call I mean as
Joe Douglas you answer the call for
anybody if somebody says what's the
market like for Sam Darden you answer
the call you are in a rebuild you are
not finding success this year so and
he's not on the level of Brady obviously
or or Aaron Donald so yeah you're gonna
answer the call for that so I'm gonna
I'm gonna go against Adams here I I do
think that that is a situation where
it's a business and I know that the
front office talked to him and said they
weren't gonna move him but you have to
listen for calls on everybody
I love Jamal Adams absolutely love Jamal
Adams he's wrong for taking this
personally that's what it comes down to
he is taking this personally if
you hear how Le'Veon Bell spoke yes
it'll be yesterday when you're listening
to this Le'Veon said you listen Joe
Douglas spoke to me after everything's
good he takes calls that's part of his
job
Jamal Adam said he wasn't ready to talk
to Joe Douglas you can't take this
personally
the Jets have won 10 football games
since they drafted Jamal Adams that's
not you Moll Adams fault but guess what
the Jets can win three or four games
without Jamal Adams because they don't
have an offensive line they don't have a
cornerback they don't have a pass rush
we're not even sure if they have a
quarterback yet although I do believe in
him when they actually get pieces around
him when you're the GM of the team what
if someone calls you and said you know
what we'll offer two ones for Jamal
Adams you have to listen that's your job
you're in the first year of a six-year
deal on an awful team it's very
frustrating because Jamal Adams came
here and said I want to be the savior I
want to turn things around
I believe him and I think his hearts in
the right place but when you take
everything so personally it doesn't feel
like you're in that for the team all the
time that's the problem here levy on
bail and Robbie Anderson the way they
spoke I'm sure they're just as upset as
him their name being every trade rumor
possible but they didn't come out and
make it personal they didn't tweet about
the GM exactly it's they're gonna trash
Baker for storming off for press
conferences you got to say hey Jamal
this is not the most professional way to
handle this and Rijos on the injury
report with the foot injury
oh I didn't see that oh man this is
gonna Jalen Ramsay that's my prediction
this is gonna be a Jameson but he number
one he doesn't play corner and he's just
as talented as a player but he has two
years left on his deal counting the
fifth-year option the leverage is not
here do I think they'll move on they
probably will I think this bridge is
completely burned but I just can't sit
here I could kill the Jets for a lot of
things Adam GaSe higher was horrible
he's a bad coach I there's a lot of the
Jets have messed up so many things I
can't sit here and kill a GM in year one
of his six year deal for answering the
phone I can't do agree yeah and I think
you're right - Connor you touched on it
you can't take it to social media like
you got to keep that stuff in-house if
we are gonna kill Baker for the way that
he acts
and says things in the media I think we
have to do the same thing with Jamal
Adams you want to be upset that's fine
just keep it in-house you don't need to
be tweeting about it all the time
yeah I know I don't we don't have time
to talk about this a whole lot because
we don't know all the details but we
were going to talk about this so I'm
gonna bring it up I just I glanced on my
phone cuz it wouldn't stop lighting up
Trent Williams announced he had cancer
and it was found six years ago but team
doctor said it was minor but he said he
nearly lost his life so we were gonna
talk about Trent Williams who ended his
holdout with the Redskins and then said
he failed the physical because the
helmet didn't fit right which I've never
heard of that before ever but now he's
saying that they found a growth six
years ago and team doctor said it was
minor so maybe this is where some of the
hey I hate you guys actually comes from
is that they told him it was minor and
it wasn't how do you have a minor growth
that's like being a little pregnant like
nope that's horrible yeah and obviously
this news is kind of it's happening
absolutely bored so we don't have a
whole lot of information on there but a
lot of people coming out and not loving
the medical staff of their team this
year yeah that's something the Jets did
mess up to be clear was the caleche a
family thing this is this that's really
sucks for Trent how fumbled that entire
thing was and I mean we have to assume
here we'll never play another down for
them right just know I would assume not
there's no way could you imagine if your
doctor was like it's fine like that
can't it's just a little cancer you'll
be all right and then you're like oh no
you're still good for Sunday you'll be
all right
right it's crazy that's a weird
situation to be in for for him it
absolutely it without a doubt okay let's
move on here because I'm a little
shell-shocked by well if anything
changes while we're recording we'll
address it but another trade that did
happen Aqib Talib was traded to the
Miami Dolphins in basically a salary cap
dump for the st. for the Los Angeles my
goodness Rams this allows them to have
operating cap space to try to lock
jaylen Ramsey up a long term Aqib Talib
has some familiarity with Brian Flores
that's his name I want to say Chris
Greer with Brian Flores from their time
New England sounds like he's cool with
this but again another player who's on
IR so it's Naik he's gonna go suit up
for the Dolphins right away yeah and I
think this is just another salary dump
they were able to get something it's
keep to leave that he has to go to Miami
and I don't think anybody wants to do
that not this year maybe next year not
this year well it's pretty great that
he's on IR and they're letting him train
in LA like he didn't even have to go to
Miami they'll you just stay there and do
your thing we got the draft pick we
wanted the salary cap hit I'm always a
big fan of this strategy I think it
shows that Chris Grier knows what he's
doing when you when you're a willing
when you have the salary cap and you're
willing to take on a player's contract
to get more draft capital you should
always do that and on the rams side it
had to be done
it really did they need a lot of money
to keep Jalen Ramsey and you know
they're going to after the amount of
draft assets they gave up together right
and not just Jalen they actually have
some key free agents this year the
linebacker corps in Littleton is afraid
that they really like him Donte Fowler's
a free agent Michael brokers is a free
agent so there's a lot of names for the
Rams that they're gonna have to figure
out Andrew Whitworth is but I know
there's some belief that he's just gonna
retire when this is all said and done
it's getting up there and we should have
mentioned I keep Talib as a free agent
so the fact that he was traded to Miami
I don't know if we'll ever see him play
for the Dolphins maybe he will but he is
a free agent this year so that's
something to keep an eye on as well okay
last bit of NFL news guys
and this one surprised me because the
timing and I know Andy Dalton's like a
stand-up dude and he would never get
upset and say anything about this like
really say anything about it but the
Reds excuse me the bengals benched him
this week and right at the trade
deadline by doing that you're not
allowing Andy Dalton or his
representatives to go feel for a trade
which is what would normally happen if
you're a an established starting
quarterback team says hey we're gonna
see we got in for 300 Finley we're gonna
bench you for the rest year his agent
would say okay will you at least let us
go to market and try to find a trade
that's what normally happens the Bengals
are like now we don't trade players
we're just gonna sit your ass on the
bench and you're gonna watch this fourth
round or play while we continue to suck
number one I hate how the Bengals run
this organization like why hold on to
assets that you're just gonna leave
like you're gonna lose and you're gonna
get nothing in return but a comp pick
but they're so afraid of getting fleeced
in a trade that they won't their won't
let anybody leave and I also think
they're just cheap and it's like no
we've paid you we're gonna keep you yeah
I I think they also want him around to
try to help out with the rookie
quarterback but I don't know if you
don't do that way ah we do now that he's
pissed off I think that's the ideal
situation is he you get a guy like Eli
Manning who maybe will sit there and
help out the young rookie quarterback I
don't know if we're gonna see that
anymore from Andy Dalton now that he is
voiced that he wants to move on I don't
I don't hold him at fault as much for
this because he is a veteran and he has
been doing it well in the league for a
while it does suck but I understand it
from the bengals point of view well
here's the problem as well he's under
contract for next year so they have to
cut him so for the whole compensatory
pick the Bengals fumbled this let's be
real they could have got something back
for him he could have played somewhere
this year he would have been happy to
play I want to make something clear as
well
Andy Dalton was not the worst
quarterback in football this year
hardly he should be upset and he's a guy
that never gets upset over anything and
he came out and said I'm not happy about
it I don't blame him at all I think it's
there's a lot of teams right now that
are messing up simple things in the NFL
and whoever is making those decisions is
not qualified for the job they're in the
Redskins right now Bruce Allen could not
have handled this Trent Williams
situation any worse the bengals with
Andy Dalton the Jets would kolache us
Emily there are so many problems with
simple things that they aren't getting
right and I don't understand how this
continues to happen I mean this guy
could be a Chicago Bear right I was
gonna say like there are teams that he
would be he's an improvement over
Mitchell true Biscay right [ __ ] now
he's an improvement over whatever
they're doing in Miami right now he's an
improvement over Marcus Mariota and Ryan
Tannehill right now this is not a bad
he's not a bad quarterback he's not a
great quarterback by any stretch of the
imagination but let you tell me
Pittsburgh win rather and they can't
afford him I'm saying he's better than
Mason Rudolph
now for right now I don't know I mean I
know that's your guy and he might you
know he might be something eventually
but the Denver Broncos sign Andy Dalton
this is easy money like he's he's solid
at least so it's gonna be out for a
while that broken neck but when
Frankenstein breaks his neck like that's
not a good day for Joe Flacco I mean
there are so many teams where Andy don't
would be a better quarterback option so
I hate to see this happen to him like
you said Conor he's under contract for
next year so it'll be interesting to see
if they trade him or if they cut him
they are not a team that normally cuts
players because again this is the most
cheaply run franchise in football I
remember hearing a story about there was
a I'm not gonna say the players name cuz
I don't want to out any sources there's
a really good player on the west coast a
couple years ago a great player everyone
had been through to scout the guy and I
reached out to the school was like hey
just doing some legwork for an article
everyone has been out there right he's
like 31 teams have come to business
who the [ __ ] wouldn't come watch him
play he's like bengals they won't they
don't do it they wouldn't fly to the
west coast to watch a guy who eventually
was a top 10 draft pick at a position of
need they just won't do it this is the
cheapest franchise in the history of
sports problem no shortage of dollars
here in the NFL it's very profitable
organization and we take the tailgate
tour to the west coast for the price of
that ticket come on it's just it's just
sad but I will say this people ask us I
go what are the Bengals gonna do because
right now they would have the number one
pick if Ryan Finley plays well enough
then they draft chase young if he
doesn't they take tour or Joe burrow or
Justin Herbert it's that simple like
this is a an eight week audition for the
draft and if Ryan Finley shows a spark
well then you feel like you have
something to build on out of a fourth
rounder and you take chase young who's
the best defensive prospect I think most
of us have ever seen but tying it back
to the draft if you're the Bengals this
you this is actually smart and I know I
think they should have traded Andy
Dalton or let him at least look for a
trade but this does allow you to see
what you have in Ryan Finley who none of
us liked at all
but they drafted him at a point where
you do need to see what's out there I
think I liked him better than you guys
did but still I don't think that this
eight-week audition is gonna result in
him not taking a quarterback not with
two of sitting there or or your guy Joe
burrow I just yeah I don't have I think
at the end of the day they'll take a
quarterback when the top two pink I do
but
hey Ryan Finley make the most of this
chance I mean prove us wrong Brutus I I
didn't ever see starting quality traits
and Ryan Finley I saw a below-average
arm
I think he's accurate at times I mean
you watch Calvin Harmon and he's
constantly coming back for the ball he
had to slow up all the time Mike Glennon
when I watched Ryan Finley you said I
think it's Mike Glennon career backup
kind of guy but I guess he'll get his
chance to prove that he can't be a
career backup guy behind them maybe the
worst offensive line of football which
is saying Ah there's some bad ones this
year
all right let's transition to the
college side I know this first segments
run along and we appreciate you guys
having fun with us today our guy
Joe Bochy right before the show today
gets the spinner for taking a PD this is
surprising me it's a 2-time team captain
but the big tin comes in and says hey
you failed a PD we have to sit you down
on Michigan State has said they're gonna
appeal this but this is a big blow to a
team that has not been as good as we
thought they were gonna be this year
even though I don't think we expected
them to be great they have struggled the
Joe Bochy and Kenny will okis have been
the bright spots for a team that they're
two and three in conference I did not
see that one coming I'll tell you that I
think this is a guy who we've seen his
Drakh draft stock could arise and maybe
now we know why but he has been playing
a lot better this year this is really
gonna hurt him in the draft because he
was playing well and now a lot of people
will point the finger out this is why
he's playing better and it might not
have had anything to do with that but it
sucks because him I mean I could see him
going undrafted now just because he was
already a fringe like maybe three for
fourth round guy now he's probably not
gonna get that chance yeah it's a big
blow I mean it's a really big blow
especially if he can't participate in
the NFL Combine I think what Bochy you
watch the film and you love the
instincts you love his nose for the ball
I mean we've been talking to
him as a big riser and he found himself
from day three to day two this year as
Melo just said when this happens you
probably fall back to day three you
could even potentially fall out of
undrafted if teams have a serious
concern about it so for a player I know
I really liked it it's it's
disappointing and I hope you know I hope
it's not anything extremely serious I
don't really know how to say that maybe
the drug test is wrong or you never
really know what happens with these but
or I'm definitely taking something yeah
that's who could have been like it could
be a lot of things that's the problem
with peds there's a big gap and it's not
the Sammy Sosa and Mark McGwire arrow so
shooting of straight steroids to get
that strong it could be anything else
but it's gonna be something we have our
eyes on yeah it is huge all right the
big one guys right here the NCAA in a
shocking announcement comes out and says
they're gonna allow players to profit
off their likeness and name by 2021 at
the latest now I will say I don't want
to be a thief of joy but I have heard
that this is not as good of a deal as it
sounds like this is the n-c-double-a so
they're gonna put out a statement that
makes them look good but like the fine
details might not be as great as they
seem however this is good news because
we are pro player we are pro players
being able to make money off their
likeness and marketing something I've
we've actually been saying this as long
as there was a stick to football this
was my solution to pay for play and best
news of all EA Sports has already said
they will be interested in returning
NCAA football the video game as soon as
the legal stuff gets figured out here so
give me chase Young on that cover
I need this game back it would be a no
hopefully they just go ahead and create
a department bring those guys back and
start developing this game again I would
I've heard you know I'm I'm in Mad no no
if you guys know that I I've heard I
remember a couple years ago they did the
the superstar thing and the guy played
at Texas in the mode and they were like
the ground works they're like it would
be so easy for them to make this game I
mean honestly I hope they don't change a
whole lot about it I don't like men I
like in CA that ball in the way that
hand the pizzas the gameplay in men
obviously I like I like drafting players
and building teams but I know
the gameplay there so I hope that they
keep it very similar to what it was
already but I would love to have
recruiting back and you know creating
teams creating play books the transfer
portal there's just so much that I've
been missing out on the last five years
yeah this is exciting I mean NC double-a
has come out and said we will pay for
this they've said it over the years like
this is not an us issue of not wanting
to make the game this is obviously a
legality thing they're willing to find
the right number to pay for the rights
to make this game so it is exciting that
realistically guys I think NC double-a
football is gonna be back and to touch
on this I don't know if I've said this
on the show yeah Matt I didn't know you
were in Madden whenever I play franchise
mode you always [ __ ] on my team I gotta
take her thing it's like Matt Miller
tweets and it's like this team sucks and
I'm like I actually got your gamer code
and I sent it to EA and I was like
everything he does make my guy shadow
like you you got a deal with me in
person and on the game alright let's
take a break when we come back blonde
review time and we're gonna break down
top five college football games of the
weekend it is time to pick some games
and I know we're mixing things up but
Melo
please do the honors my undefeated San
Francisco 49ers in a blind review
remember we record this Thursday
afternoon comes our Friday morning so we
missed the game but Niners undefeated
Cardinals not undefeated what are they
three four and one right now but showed
some spark saw offensively what did you
see Thursday night I saw the 49ers stay
undefeated as we all predicted I know
we've been waiting for this game all
year long the 49ers at the Arizona
Cardinals this defensive line is just
too much Kyler Murray running for his
life all night long nine sacks for the
49ers with two of them coming from Bosa
this guy is making a strong push for the
Rookie of the Year I love the way
they're playing I'm sorry 49ers fans I
was wrong about my prediction at the
beginning of the year yeah the Niners do
it again and not just Nick Bosa who I
think is the not just defensive rookie
there I think he should be Rookie of the
Year might be Defensive Player of the
Year the way he's getting after it right
now the man is unstoppable with Kyler
Murray again like this offensive line is
just absolutely
awful we've seen it week in and week out
no matter how elusive he is the Niners
with Arik Armstead who's had a great
year so far with DeForest Buckner you
got two guys who were six seven in the
milled offensive line
Tyler Murch 5-7 he can't see over that
line we saw it last night struggling to
find the middle of the field again you
hate to see it because Kyler has been
explosive this year but he'd been sacked
11 times coming into this game the
Niners turning on another week like you
said Melo defense wins this one big I
like Kliff Kingsbury but he got taking a
school by Kyle Shanahan who might be I
think is right now the best coach in the
NFC and you want to talk about aging
like wine Richard Sherman with his
fourth interception on the season after
not having any last year this 49ers
defense is hungry they are fun to watch
and I'm with you Matt Nick Bosa right
now is your Defensive Player of the Year
oh baby I love it I love it alright
let's get into the college pics guys
number eight Georgia minus six and a
half at number six Florida over/under
sixty four and a half I cannot believe
that we live in a world where Florida's
ranked higher than Georgia but
congratulations I was wrong about them
and they are the problem with I have
what this game is two things when I
think about it I think of that dumbass
country band Florida Georgia line which
I absolutely hate I just I hate I hate
that band so much nicer second thing is
that they don't let them call this the
world's largest outdoor cocktail party
anymore which is just horseshit
but I'm taking Georgia I think the dogs
role in this one they get a little bit
back on track the run game I think it's
good enough Florida's best pass rushers
have been banged up a little bit I don't
expect a ton from Jake from but I think
John Drake Swift is good enough to get
the Bulldogs win yeah and the Bulldogs
are as a favorite in this one and
anytime I take the underdog Matt which
is what I'm doing right here huh is the
super underdog locksmith game of the
week to bet your money on because I
don't have the nuts or the money to bet
my own money on so I'm going with
Florida I love Kyle Trask I love this
defense if they can get after Jake from
a little bit create some pressure he's
gonna turn the ball over like he did at
South Carolina
DeAndre Swift is gonna be running all
over the field here but I like the
Gators in this one I think that defense
is too much I think Kyle Trask might
actually be a pretty damn good
quarterback - I'm going with Florida in
this one this could be one of the best
games of the year
I'm still gonna roll with the favor in
the Bulldogs I think Florida they'll be
ready to roll I agree with you Melo that
Trask is fun to watch they obviously
have a lot of good players on that
defensive line
I just think DeAndre swift is the
difference maker in this game if he
could hit a home run at some point of
the game which I believe he will I think
it'll be the difference I don't really
love that line for Georgia I think
that's too big I think that's pretty
juicy that Florida coverage that but I
think Georgia wins the game the 64 and a
half was surprising to me I think I
would take the under yeah it shouldn't
be that highest scoring of a game but
we've been wrong before yeah a couple of
times we're wrong about this team in the
opener at least I was and this guy was
Miami
oh they're bad they play at Florida
State 10 years ago you would have
canceled everything you were doing in
the world to watch this game but now
it's like oh those two teams played so
Miami at Florida State Florida State's
the favorite by three at the home field
advantage over unders 48 and a half
which tells you just how shitty these
offenses are no offense guys I hope you
get I want these teams to be good ok
football is better when Florida State
and Miami are good like these teams have
so much swag and I think Florida State's
gonna be hiring a new head coach I know
they say like if Willie Tiger get hit by
a bus like we're not gonna go after
Urban Meyer
maybe you should somebody else maybe you
should what's pj fleck doing do you want
to come down south I am gonna take
Florida State in this one though I just
think it comes down to talent when you
have teams like this and I like Manny
Diaz and I hope that he gets Miami
turned around Miami is so flat right now
and it's just really offensively and I
know they have some dudes that are young
that we're we really like their
potential especially deejay Dallas
running back and and the tight end whose
names were completely expect me brevin
Jordan but I think Florida State is just
the more experienced team right now and
I feel like they have more playmakers
yeah I do too and I think it's gonna
come down to a battle in the trenches I
mean that offensive line of Miami has
looked terrible they got destroyed by
Florida and I don't think it's gotten
much better I think cam akers is gonna
have a good game
yeah he's the difference maker here he's
really coming over this year I think had
four touchdowns last week I don't think
my could do anything to stop him and I
like their linebackers there's they have
been difference-makers either so I'm
gonna go with Florida State in this one
as well yeah cam akers 300 rushing yards
in his last two games combined and a cup
catches to mix it in they have him run
in you know direct snap a little more
there's getting him involved and for as
talented as a player he is that's really
good to see it's been a nice bounce-back
year for cam who's easily gonna probably
go over the thousand yard mark this
season he might do it this weekend
I like Florida State yeah and Marvin
Wilson cam akers to prospects I really
like Florrick State I want to mention
that right number seven Oregon big win
over Washington last week they're the
favorite only by four and a half at USC
the over/under sixty two and a half it
is a big one I want to take USC so badly
in this one but Melo and I are tied on
the year and I can't afford to lose any
share money Matt I'm taking Oregon I
[ __ ] I'm taking USC I do I think USC
Michael Pittman jr. is gonna have a
massive game I know that Melo loves this
Oregon left tackle I got a chance to
watch him on my flight home yesterday he
is gonna be a top five pick when it's
all said she's only a soft away
sophomore he is amazing he's the best
love tackle in casual right now but left
tackles don't win football games to the
college like Michael Pittman jr. has the
day of his life may okay second biggest
day of his life cuz the Utah game no
one's ever topping that for him but I'll
take USC I'll be that guy and I'm gonna
go Oregon for one of the reasons you
just said that offensive line I think
that they're finally getting the running
game going in Oregon they did it last
week and I like what they're doing I
think defensively they're probably gonna
allow some points I'm gonna take the
over at 62 and I have I think we're
gonna see a lot of points here but I'm
taking Oregon I I don't think that USC
defense can do anything to stop them
Justin Herbert probably has a big game
and I really think that this organ
rushing attack is going to be the
difference-maker
Herbert's gonna have the pass protection
he needs in this one that offensive line
across every spot is very talented USC
is one of the more jekyll-and-hyde teams
in the country this year I can't figure
them out at all but I know what Oregon
is an Oregon will win this football game
all right well he's confident he's very
confident right another one in the
pac-12 number nine Utah favorited by
three favorite
favored by 304 Washington over 42 feet
on this one my god now this is a sneaky
game because I think Jacob Eason could
go off
we know that Washington has some dudes
in the secondary if I'm Utah I hand the
ball to Zach Mouse 33 times in this game
and say run the football young man don't
put this game in the hands of the
quarterback let the Utah defensive line
which is exceptional get after Jacob
Eason and control the clock run the ball
I think if you taught does that they can
win this game
yeah I think I think this is gonna be a
very good game even though Washington
has dropped some games they're not
ranked in the top 25 I think they're
gonna play with Utah I think it's gonna
be close but I actually think that
Huntly the quarterback at Utah has been
playing very well I think he's gonna be
the difference maker here I do want to
see what Trey Adams can do against
Bradley and I that's gonna be a very
good matchup to watch if you're looking
for a good scouting matchup here so Utah
I'm gonna take them I'll take the points
as well I think that defense is that
secondary is just too much in this game
I think Washington knows that Utah has
to run the ball and I also think
Washington has the corners that can
survive in man coverage whether it's
press or whether on an island whatever
they ask them to do against these Utah
receivers that's why I like Washington
with the upset here and this would be my
upset of the week right here I really
really think Washington can win this
game Jacob Eason yeah this is a big test
but we've seen this Utah defense beat
before by that USC team we were just
talking about I do probably think it'll
be a low-scoring game but this these
teams have great defenses specifically
they have a lot of NFL talent in the
secondary and that'll be the difference
in this one I like the upset for the
Huskies oh there we go we're all
disagreeing this week I like it it's
better that way not on this one though
number 15 SMU how about Shane Michelle
my god look yeah mazing at quarterback
the Texas keep their own got no they
didn't they didn't know he looks thicker
though he's got another year to play at
SMU too because he took a redshirt last
year so we get to see him short though
he's like 6 to 5 forget we're in this
age of tiny quarterbacks number 15 SMU
at number 20 for Memphis College GameDay
will
yet this one because they don't want to
go to Minnesota even though they're
undefeated up there as well
Memphis is the favorite though by six
the over-under is a whopping 72 and I'm
rolling with the Mustangs this team
hasn't been this good since they were
paying Craig James they've got it
figured out Shae Michele is the best
player that no one's talking about
college football right now no I don't
think he's a draft prospect necessarily
but what he's done so far just coming to
SMU it's not all him I mean this team
has been very very well coached they
there have talent around him but the
moving bushel into this roster has
completely changed everything for them
so big credit to him and like you said
Melo will you see him back next year as
well yeah I do think we will I like SMU
in this game I like Xavier Jones their
running back I think he's kind of meant
underrated 14 rushing touchdowns this
year and I know a lot of people probably
not going to tune in to this game
because it's the American Conference and
a shame you against Memphis there are
some really good players in this game
and I do think that it has warranted a
college game day visit Kenneth gay
Doyle's another running back just a
freshman at Memphis they're turning out
just running back after running back in
that program this is gonna be a good
game I'm taking SMU and my boy Shane
Boucher I'm going with the upset as well
all three of us picking the upset here
in SMU this would actually be a bigger
upset than the Washington one I just
picked
I'm surprised maybe it's because it's at
Memphis and I know Memphis is seven and
one SMU hasn't lost the game thanks to
future number one overall XFL pick Shane
boo shell I'm really excited to watch
this one and I do think the Mustangs win
it is top five time and this is gonna be
a good win it is our top five hunting's
no we're not talking about my ex-wives
or child support or any of those things
we're keeping it sports related for the
most part I believe and Melo you
actually came up with all this so I'm
gonna let you take it away I figured we
would do a player that haunts us just a
scary player we already kind of teased
it on Instagram yesterday a draft take
that it keeps haunting us a game and
then two random ones I'll start it off
here one of the scariest players in the
nation for me right now is CD lamb
because any time this dude has the ball
in the open field he's probably going to
score it
not even that yes he can it's that he's
probably going to I've watched five
texas defenders try to tackle this dude
i'm gonna hate scouting him because i
think i'm gonna have to go back and
watch this tape even more Seanie lamb is
going to hunt me he's one of my least
favorite / favorite Oklahoma players
because as soon as he's gone from there
I'm gonna love this kid I have a really
interesting one cuz he's not playing
anymore but the player that's haunting
me is Peyton Manning because he called
Christopher Johnson and said you should
hire Adam GaSe and Christopher Johnson's
eyes lit up and he listened and because
of that the Jets are awful
so Peyton Manning even after you leave
the cults and stop beating the Jets you
still haunt them in different ways yeah
and I really thought Melo was gonna go
here so I'm gonna change mine because I
had I had marking room in there because
he had he had Trent Richardson
absolutely killed Texas in the 2010 BCS
Championship game most Alabama running
backs were everywhere that day we could
not stop them Marcell Darius would be
another answer but there's one player
who actually has [ __ ] me twice
I mean he's breaking news worst moments
of my life as a sports fan were caused
by one person one time against my team
one time for my team Michael Crabtree
making the most ridiculous college catch
I've ever seen when he played for Texas
Tech to beat our Texas Longhorns and
then in the Super Bowl John Harbaugh
calls three [ __ ] straight vert roots
to Michael Crabtree suik ass who drops
the ball in the end zone
the Niners lose the Super Bowl after one
of the best comebacks until the 28th
three-game so Michael Crabtree when I
die young it will be his fault all right
I hate Michael Crabtree but I like but
she's having a lot of the podcast do you
hate me
didn't he wear number five at Texas Tech
as well yeah speaking of yeah speaking
of Texas Tech draft takes that we missed
on Matt you're so famous for yours but I
think I've had the worst one ever you
have yeah I thought Pat mahomes was
gonna be very very bad we talked about
it last week
was like Cuba for it thankfully Conor
kind of bailed me out cuz he did you but
he I really thought that Pat mahomes was
gonna be like out of the league by now
and I guess but he hasn't MVP under his
belt I really thought he was a system
quarterback I didn't think his arm was
that strong I was wrong and that's
probably going to haunt me there's a lot
of people in the Joplin area that like
to bring it up often but now I'm a
[ __ ] Chiefs fan and he I have to watch
him ball out every week yeah mine is
pretty similar here but it's because he
is not balling out it is Josh Rosen who
got drafted into one of the scariest
situations got traded into one of the
scariest situations and has just not
been good and ironically no quarterback
from that class has been very good
except Lamar Jackson but Josh Rosen
wants my QB 1 and I don't feel so good
about that one fellas it's gonna haunt
me for a little bit no in mine the
famous one I hate not only did I have
Trent Richardson very high I actually
had him number three overall in the 2010
draft but I said he was the best running
back prospect I had ever evaluated which
at the time was true but that's bad you
can't say that when I'm old enough to
have seen LaDainian Tomlinson Cobb oh
it's not a great look
the Trent Richardson one is bad there
are others I mean there are a lot of
others that one is definitely the one
that's me I'm spitting that is the one
that stands out most though where I'm
like if I could go back in time and
change any of my Draft grades it would
be that one just so people couldn't like
send that tweet once a year it's there's
like an anniversary once a year but you
know like I actually miss really bad on
Rueben foster as well I loved Rueben
foster I thought he was gonna be amazing
and he just has not turned out to be you
know I had I had Joey Bosa tulo item 5
over 6 overall but the way he's played
there are others like it's just those
guys when it's like you have them really
high and they end up completely out of
the league real fast that's where you're
like oh [ __ ] but there have been others
were like I Jameis Winston number one in
2015 I know he's still a starter in the
NFL but I tell you that's not a great I
feel great about no I wouldn't either
the game that has haunted me Matt you
already talked about it it is the 2008
Texas at Texas Tech game we've talked
about it on here before and I don't want
to start crying because I'm already
snotty this game almost literally broke
my heart I almost had a heart attack I
was supposed to go out that night for a
Halloween party it was November first it
was a Saturday Texas was number one in
the nation on their way to play in a
national championship and that [ __ ]
Michael Crabtree catch killed me ruined
my whole mood
I almost got broken up with because I
was just being pissed poor attitude that
whole night real debbie downer and I
still think about it all the time I
think about that play and that cat well
and like Texas had really come back in
that game I think like that was that
like they scored 27 points in the second
half they had Michael Huff or Aaron Ross
and Earl Thomas in that secondary and
not one of them could push him out of
bounds and just end the game and we
probably win another national
championship if they just get Michael
Crabtree down Graham Harrell man number
five at Texas Tech is not good for you
mahomes wore five at Texas Tech that's
why five attack look at their roster
right now whoever's wearing five sorry
Connor go ahead no it's okay I feel for
you in my moment like that that I still
think of to this day is Carlos Beltran
striking out in the NLCS when the Mets
had the bases loaded in the bottom of
the ninth inning
he's stared at a curveball Adam
Wainwright to strike out and not go to
the World Series like you think of all
the strikeouts in baseball and you're
like man you know it happens a lot you
strikeout to lose a game you know like
he's watched strike three to not go to
the World Series and I was devastated
and I know the Mets have made a World
Series since then they haven't won one
but they made one but that year in oh
six that met seemed was so much better
than the 2015 see they were loaded they
spent all this money they had a great
team they were playing great they got
the bases loaded where the comeback was
on and I hope the Mets hire Carlos
Beltran as their manager so we get this
Redemption story but that until then
will forever bother me as a sports fan
the fact that he looked at it he didn't
that's the thing if you swing it's like
well shitty try
but you stared at it and he was such a
good met people forget that he was a
great player for the Mets but that's
what he's remembered for no lucas duda
throw that didn't make the cut
no I mean I was there for that so I
don't I don't I try not to think of that
very often yeah I think every adult when
you're a kid you're like extra haunted
by things so I disagree I take things so
much harder now like obviously I'm just
like man some of those Niners Cowboys or
Niners Packers games as a kid like I
would throw [ __ ] in our house like I
would be breaking things so I guess I
don't do that as much anymore so there's
that my game that haunts me and I saw
our buddy Manuel ah so he tweeted this
today there was the Yahoo Sports thing
like tell me a Sports Khairy story in
six words and his was Colts down Colts
down and that's it for me
when Marcel Darius broke Colt McCoy's
shoulder in the 2010 BCS Championship
game uh so many people were talking [ __ ]
about Alabama is amazing you guys can't
beat Alabama and I'm like yeah like we
can beat Alabama we were the number one
team in the country and then Colt gets
just smashed in the first drive of the
first quarter he goes out and you can
talk to any Texas fan anyone who covered
Texas any Texas player so a lot of very
biased people they will all tell you
though like Texas was going to win this
game I think almost did anyway but it
was very close regardless the
quarterback I block him out Garrett I am
I don't remember yeah yeah someone
Gilbert that's who it was
not a great moment of my life for sure
that game still haunts me because it was
so close and this other one that haunts
me I'm next up I'm gonna go with the
Willis McGahee injury watching that play
live and seeing it in the national
championship game I really liked Willis
McGahee coming on strong that season
rooting for him and then watching his
knee just get detached from his body it
made me want to vomit for one and then
just losing a good player at the biggest
game of his life so far
that was terrible and then I can't watch
it again I saw it once almost threw up
even if I start to see Willis McGahee on
the right side of the field of any
highlight
I'm like I better you look away I don't
know what's about to happen here mine
actually was the opposite of that like
instant awful gross injury mine was just
the slow decay of David right and not to
make this like super Mets heavy but he
had spinal stenosis and it was like all
the things he had do to come back and
then he'd be hurt like three games later
and this just went on for years and
years it's like you watch one of like
your favorite baseball players just
slowly not even be able to physically
play baseball anymore that's the injury
that I hated the most yeah and it's like
when it comes to these things like
hauntings it's always gonna be your
favorite teams your favorite players and
thinks mine was I'll never forget this
because I was helping my dad do
something
and so it was the the Fiesta Bowl Ohio
State Notre Dame and I like didn't want
to know what was happening
I had a DVR and I was gonna help my dad
and then I was gonna go watch it and I
think it was actually Melo text me and
he was like oh my god I don't like what
he's like Jaylon Smith I was like what
do you what do you mean and I'm like
freaking out and when I saw it like I
thought I was gonna throw up
like I really did I loved Jalen I had a
great relationship with him he was at
Notre Dame I thought he was he was
perfect as a linebacker prospect
absolutely perfect and so to have that
happen in his last college game
you're just so disappointed for the
player and then there was you know the
idea that he might never walk again you
might never play again so there it's
nice that now he's playing it I believe
in all-pro linebacker level but in the
moment I've never been more affected by
a player's injury I remember like you
said the Willis McGahee injury where
it's like I might throw up that was
really hard to watch and there have been
others
who's the Cincinnati Kenya Martin his
injury absolutely disgusting but the
Jaylon Smith one was and and I didn't
see it live but it's the one where I
mean I thought about that [ __ ] for days
it was like I mean it was like I won't
say the other time in my life but been a
little depressed but you know what I'm
talking about
Connor knows what I'm talking about but
like I just I couldn't let go of it for
days that he got hurt yeah that was a
tough one
I know I said myself hopefully you did
but this one is still haunting me and
hopefully it gets
cured soon because when they announced
that they were no longer going to make
the NCAA football games
I was actually depressed that really hit
me hard
if anybody of you followed me on Twitter
you know because anytime there's news I
tweet about it I desperately need this
game back we already kind of talked
about it I'm still playing a video game
on a system they don't even make anymore
a Playstation 3 I still have to have it
because I still want to fire up NCAA
football 14 sometimes that I'm gonna
college until we get a new I was still
married a long time ago I was still
married
that's probably what caused my divorce
is I never got over the depression of
losing that football game and couldn't
focus on anything else my random one
here is the pass interference challenge
I mean it ruins every weekend now nobody
tries it anymore because it's such a
hoax that I think it's just disappearing
thank God but it was so infuriating
these first couple of weeks when you're
like oh yeah that's P I good challenge
and they're like yeah I call in the
field stands and then you're like oh
like you know that wasn't P I that's a
good challenge and they're like oh the
call in the field stands
it was the most aggravating beginning to
a football season since the replacement
refs that's how bad it was
yeah no you're absolutely right and my
last one and again back to baseball Melo
and I were at this game Game seven the
World Series Giants Royals an improbable
run that the Royals going from that
shouldn't have been there and then
winning the wild-card which we were
there for that night was one of the
greatest nights of my life and then to
take the Giants to Game seven and you're
kind of this feeling of like I was happy
to be here the [ __ ] Royals are in
Game seven in sack Kauffman even if we
lose I'm gonna be okay until Alex Gordon
gets stranded on third and I was not
okay so I think and it's different
because they did win the next year but I
still we're never gonna see the Royals
win another World Series especially now
that Mike Matheny czar our coach but if
they could've won two in a row like
back-to-back I would have been good for
life yeah I don't know that they've
they're never gonna make the playoffs
again I don't think they would've won
against the Mets had they not lost in
games
seven another player that hunts me and I
absolutely hate this Madison Bumgardner
oh [ __ ] that guy if he's listening with
you on that I'll gladly get my ass
kicked trying to fight him because I
hate him with a passion yeah he's a
menace an absolute monster is Madison
Bumgarner this is a great time for you
guys to tweet us at 6 football let us
know who do you who hunt you which
players which games which moments haunt
you because yeah there there's a lot of
great ones out there and I'm sure all
yours don't revolve around the Royals
and Mets draft on draft time we got some
iTunes questions in here so don't forget
that is a great way to get your name and
question read on the air and answer it
on the air also you can watch this on
youtube so check that out Bleacher
Report's youtube channel is the stick to
football play last time laughing cuz
Melo is waving at the camera which is -
there's so many things that Connor now
were talking with us in London and we
should have done it today but I'm still
jet-lagged I just got home is that we
should start doing special things for
the viewers I don't want to go like all
like you know around the horn having
like signs and stuff but like I want to
start doing things that are only for the
viewers so like when I get mad encodes
I'm gonna just start holding up yeah
it's good in front of the little unnamed
tablet that we use here no free
marketing all right first question from
it's a bust
do you think after Michigan's blow in
verse Notre Dame it clicked that Shay
Patterson is trash and they should've
been pounding the rock this whole time
they should have known that [ __ ] last
year because the only way they went last
year was when they gave Kron Higden the
ball so if it's taken Jim Harbaugh two
years to figure this out he's an idiot
that might also be the case but I think
what Michigan really learned was that if
they can force quarterbacks to play
badly and book completed like eight of
24 passes if you can create you know bad
if you can just hey we're gonna make the
other quarter I play badly you can win
games that said Ohio State's going to
beat Michigan by 63 points yeah I think
the weather conditions probably played
into that more than anything I'll
guarantee when we see Michigan strap up
again they're still gonna air the ball
out they've got two pretty good running
backs Haskins and Charbonnet they just
they still like to throw the ball and
they believe in shape Patterson and I
don't think that's going to change
regardless of what he does well I think
the problem was coming into the year
Michigan was discussed as having one of
the best wide receiver trios in the
country and I don't think that's
necessarily changed obviously be like
Alabama Clemson maybe even Oklahoma
better but this was a team built on
superstar recruiting at the wide
receiver position
but the quarterback can't get them the
ball but you always like to believe that
he'll get better and those guys will
bail him out and it's just too much to
ask so I don't think it's as simple as
the question is worded although I did
like the question I was shocked how
badly they beat Notre Dame although I
think we all said Notre Dame was due for
the classic Irish letdown at some point
and and I think when it comes down to it
with this if say Michigan season no it's
just they learned that they can win that
way but at some point teams are gonna
shut down the run as well next question
also from itunes killzone 82 that's a
cool name gamertag it really is if they
run the table and win the big 12 would
an undefeated baylor team have a shot of
getting into the play horse - yeah
they'd be an automatic as the winner of
the big 12 right there wouldn't be an
automatic but i think that they would
put themself in there because you're
gonna have to be Oklahoma twice to do it
what's Baylor ranked right now they are
rain eight I think number 12 they're
undefeated in the ranked 12 they might
not then this there's a lot of
disrespect you look at the okay Paul
Finebaum they played nobody
they started off the season with stephen
f austin UT san antonio and rice they
barely beat Texas Tech they played well
against Oklahoma State have they left
the state of Texas that's why I guess
yeah Stillwater it's almost act yeah I
mean pretty much it's not a far trip so
I I don't think that we will have to
worry about this but I will play along
with the hypothetical I think they have
a chance because they would beat
Oklahoma twice they would have to kill
Oklahoma one of those times I mean it
would have to be like what Kansas State
did to him or worse but I don't think
we'll have to worry about that man the
real question is who's gonna beat them
when they play Texas who's gonna win
when they play like this I'm done I
think I'm off I'm off
all right absolutely stuff you barely
beat Kansas and then you lose to TCU
talk to me next year I'm out I'm out I'm
out I wouldn't get your hopes up for
next year either but I'm over it they I
don't even know who they play this
weekend cuz I don't cut their own by so
they'll probably lose case days gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of them
bar Dale's 965 but the rumors about the
Jets looking to move levy on do you
think this will make him want to ask for
a trade in the offseason so I I think
this is very simple when levy ah was a
free agent any team in the NFL could
have had him in the Jets were the only
team negotiating I think that tells you
a lot about his market out there this is
dude make it 15 million dollars a year
to play running back no I don't think he
can ask for a trade I don't think
anyone's gonna trade for him it's the
problem I mean he tried that before he
sat out for a year I think he actually
just really likes playing for the Jets
he's been good let me say that it's been
great very good he's been their best
player by far but I don't think there's
a trade market for him no yes Sally
maybe a team like the 49ers but they
don't need it they don't want to pay a
running back I mean they already paid
seven Coleman and they're getting the
job done with three other guys so I
don't know that Le'Veon Bell is going to
San Francisco yeah his cap number for
2020 is pretty large I don't really see
him on the move and I'll be in the
minority to say if you're the Jets but
Sam's Arnold's what are you just gonna I
mean if you're not gonna extend Robbie
Anderson after your trade Le'Veon Bell
what do you think is can happen to
salmon Arnold
oh yeah he's gonna play with Street free
agents you don't need the cat money the
team has 60 million before they make any
cuts going they back here a good player
yeah keep someone good for once how
about that and Le'Veon has already come
out and he's been way more content with
everything that Jamal Adams so yeah I
don't think so I don't think so I think
Jamal Adams has a much higher chance of
being moved in levy on bail yeah yeah I
agree
all right trav Alex 1973 also from
iTunes if the Falcons were to get the
number two pick behind the Dolphins
would it be worth it to explore a Julio
trait and draft Jerry Judi what would
that trade package look like travel up
the alley what if your first name is
buddy know you draft chase young and you
feel
amazing about yourself you take your
pants off and you dance in the draft
room you hear the number two pick and
traffic chase young this is easy I love
Jerry judy we already have Calvin Ridley
there's I mean no you you write the
[ __ ] name on the card and you send it
in you trap chase young I mean if
they're sitting in there at pick number
two
I wouldn't go receiver I might go
quarterback here
and try to move on from Matt Ryan I
don't think it'd be receiver I would go
chase young because I love him
passionately and I don't even mean that
figuratively I mean it literally I love
chase young and I would draft him Matt
Ryan is only 34 I don't think you move
on I think this has it played that you
know his wife's name is Sarah Marshall
people forget that I think Matt Ryan's
better than any quarterback in this
class right now I agree I agree with you
Connor I like Matt Ryan I think he's
surrounded by an epic oh Qing and a
really bad he might have been built by
Kyle Shanahan though like what has he
done without Kyle Shanahan he's had some
big years I think statistically he has
right I would change into an amazing
receivers like if I end up with number
two find the Dolphins I call them and
say listen we're not gonna draft a
quarterback we'll give you a third-round
pick you do it's 49ers day whatever
player you want oh you want to move up a
pic yeah give us a third ok we're kind
of thinking about it we've been fielding
you're worried that they'll trade out
like seriously if you end up with a
number-two pick or the number three pick
I would see hey wink-wink nudge-nudge
we're not gonna take a quarterback we
want chase young let us secure that deal
because you mean you can't let that guy
pass Vic Beasley had that one magical
year and it sucked Tech McKinley hasn't
been great chase young could completely
change this franchise I mean look at
what Nick Bose is doing for the 49ers
right now that who I am no I know you
are or depending on the week I don't
know if you are alright last question
our guy paddy Chamberlain is Andrew
Thomas written in ink as the best tackle
in the 2020 draft class or is there a
chance someone surpasses him how does he
stack up against the top tackles the
last few draft classes uh I don't think
it's an Inc just yet I actually like
Tristan Dwarfs
I like Alex Leatherwood I like Austin
Jackson Alabama's other
Oh Ellis says his name I like him a lot
as well Jedrek wills wills that's right
yeah my name did my brain did a thing so
I like him a lot now as far as the best
tackles the last couple years I I mean I
liked Jonah Williams a lot he was number
eight on my board I did not really have
any tackles in 2008 on missing still
just seems like a a big Mahler I'd
almost view me right tackle
I'd like Stanley and Tunsil better than
him yeah that's why I don't know you him
is like something special that we
haven't seen in a long time I think next
year when we start talking about Sewell
at left tackle that's gonna be probably
different but for Andrew Thomas I like
him
quite a bit but I don't think he's
anything extraordinary that we haven't
seen in the last couple draft you know
who he reminds me of and I meant to
bring this up a couple shows ago I like
the workshop thing he reminds me of lila
collins in college and i know that
college has played all over for the
cowboys to play garbage play tackle
andrew thomas i i also don't know if
he's six five and i hope he is yeah i
don't think so yes there's a lot of
power in his game and maybe it won't
matter it didn't matter with i say a win
didn't really matter with Jonah Williams
a whole lot but so her question yeah
right well that's weird she answer the
question no I don't like him more than
any of the tackle the the top tackles
we've seen in a long time I would have
tonsil ahead of him I'd I'm Stanley
ahead of him I would have Jonah Williams
ahead of him so if you're ranking him
against guys like that then then
absolutely not he would probably be on
like a mic McGlinchey level for me
that's what I was gonna say I was gonna
say he's very comparable than Mike
McGlinchey if you're looking and that's
a good player yeah it is the league
needs offensive lineman so badly right
now that you're right Matt where he's
not Laremy Tunsil I thought sons was
pretty special Ronnie Stanley was very
very good I wouldn't write it in ink but
I feel good about what you're getting in
answered Thomas yeah the only thing
that's an ink for me right now is that
chase young is the number one overall
player in the draft yeah that Jerry Judy
is the number two overall player have to
everything else yeah it's somewhat fluid
I'm not moving off that like I'm good
what about a CUDA a corner ok the three
things for this dark brown at D tackle
ok I feel really good about those four
positions everything else is pretty flew
Isaiah win
as I went Isaiah Simmons linebacker I
like what about Trey Smith that guard
yeah what about the Andres Swift at
running back no I like Jonathan Taylor
alright fair enough I like them both I
have them ranked side-by-side I really
should do a show maybe its next Friday
show written in ink yeah written in E or
we should just run through our big
boards I know we haven't done that in a
while and so that would give us a week
to prepare but before we go to LSU
Alabama maybe we just do a big board
show I'm good with that if that's what
our listeners well yeah let us know if
you'd be interested in a big board show
where we talk about where we're
different on guys and give some short
scouting thoughts let us know because I
saw your tight enlisted and we're very
different on it yeah I wouldn't look at
it too much because I have know a lot of
tied into work but I did change up my
big board so you don't have the same one
as me anymore yeah I've changed mine
they're priced all the same so all right
get your big boards ready for next
Friday listeners let us know and also
definitely hit us up if you want to come
to the tailgate Alabama LSU 8:00 a.m. on
the quad food drinks cornhole koozies
stickers good times I tweeted this and I
really thought that was clever it'll be
a day that you either can't remember or
won't forget a 100% guarantee that and
that's where we'll leave you for Connor
and Mello we'll be back Monday Connor
and I will be normal schedule next week
Monday afternoon check us out on iTunes
stitcher Spotify and YouTube